l'édition 2008 du michelin sort cette
semaine le guide le plus redouté des
grands chefs principales informations
cette année marseille la ville de
marseille compte son premier restaurant
trois étoiles la cuisine méditerranéenne
de gérald passédat entre dans la cour
des grands nicolas lemarignier pierre
malacarnet le petit nice à marseille sa
vue imprenable ses spécialités de
poissons et désormais c'est trois
étoiles les marseillais en rêvait le
guide michelin l'a fait pour gérald
passédat le chef du restaurant cette
consécration culinaire c'est plein de
bonnes choses à venir
ça ne changera pas les prix ça changera
que les clients vont réserver de plus en
plus la renommée va devenir
international alors qu'elle était
national et régional
bref que les fans se rassurent la
bouillabaisse façon passédat restera la
même changement de décor direction paris
william ledeuil et le chef de la kitchen
galerie depuis six ans il marie
tradition et ingrédients exotiques
exemples étonnants avec les moules
marinières et puis mes mollets avec de
la citronnelle de la feuille de lyme
lorsque j'ai vu les cocos du galon du
galanga tout petit peu de ce no man's
quitteront à la fin aujourd'hui william
ledeuil décroche sa première étoile au
michelin
contrairement au chef marseillais pour
lui ça ne change pas grand chose
j'ai toujours avoir cette envie de
continuer de faire des plats nos
gouvernants et puis les prix n'ont pas
bougé d'un centime non plus alors on va
vous pouvez faire le travail
tous les grands chefs le dise la
meilleure recette pour obtenir une
étoile c'est surtout de ne pas courir
après